really
you think i need to introduce today's
guest neil degrasse tyson
only the most famous scientist maybe in
human history by
number of searches and the prominence
that he has
and the impact he's had on the universe
there's really no one better to host on
the into the impossible podcast
and neil truly showed up with all
cylinders firing it's a really
wide-ranging
interview that discussed his his life
his
tactics and techniques to get through
the day his thoughts on aging
his thoughts even on self-confidence and
protection
things that i don't think he's talked
about so frequently in the past
so i try to go deep not cover the same
normal things like how are you get to be
such a good writer he has
one simple answer one prescription just
do
the work and he did the work and he
continues to do the work i think he was
maybe even writing his
16th book as we were having this
conversation you won't want to miss it
so please if you want to hear the
entirety of our interview
not just the hour-long mega segment
of q a that we engaged in and that was
so
terribly enjoyable for me but if you
also want to hear
his answers to my patented thrilling
three final questions
the existential questions that are so
unique in neil's case you will not want
to miss
what he comes up with you will need to
subscribe to my mailing list if you want
to hear them now at least
while you're watching this video on
youtube otherwise you can wait about a
month i'll post them up there
if you want to be a supporter of the
podcast it really doesn't cost you
anything
just subscribe and you'll get those
answers and
even more from today's wonderful guest
neil degrasse tyson
so with that i'm just going to go
straight into the interview we kick it
off
over a fine bottle of abarolo
and think about the founder of
observational
astronomy at least with a telescope none
other than my hero galileo galilei
enjoy this episode of into the
impossible with dr neil
degrasse tyson
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
anyway today everybody i am speaking
with a
legend with a influence on me uh both
personally and professionally
and sad to say although i'm not terribly
sad to say because i made my kids day
because neil degrasse tyson
is my son's favorite astrophysicist do
you know how that feels neil
when your own son no your next question
should be son how many astrophysicists
do you know
see that that you wanna you wanna get
the the the background data on that
statistic well you know it's funny with
him
um i i always make note that astronomers
are the least
likely people to know the names of
constellations
if you're ever at a party with an
astronomer and you ask them what's that
constellation over there they go how am
i supposed to know i'm an astrophysicist
uh so i taught my son to say no matter
when daddy asked you when he was three
i said whenever we're at uh hosting
other professors and
daddy asks you what phase is the moon in
isaac
i said uh just say waxing gibbous moon
and they won't know the difference
because they have no idea the phases are
the most basic astronomical phenomena
and he would do that and then and then i
would say that's true for maybe
half of the professional astrophysicist
wouldn't know
because they come to it from physics and
some other some are even geologists who
became planetary scientists
and so they don't have tap roots
in the community of amateur astronomers
right that's the one field where when
you invoke the word amateur it's
actually a badge of honor
right right if you're an amateur
astronomy means you own it typically you
own a telescope you've gone out in the
cold dark of night and everyone thinks
you're crazy
they're similar profiles to bird
watchers right
where are you going why to do what you
know
these these are the questions you have
to respond to when people ask
you what you're doing and so so i have
deep amateur astronomy tap roots so yes
i
i can name many of the constellations
and generally i do know what phase the
moon is in and when an eclipse is coming
so i'm i'm in that the the the third
to as many as half who that actually do
have knowledge of
the night sky well i never miss an
opportunity to tease my
fellow astro uh professionals uh by
saying to them
you know if you were a professor of
international relations it's not like
we'd expect you to know where mexico is
or anything like that
[Laughter]
diminishing standards here in the app
that's funny yeah
but by the way just uh just to riff a
little more on the concept of
amateur astronomer the you know
if you were a neurosurgeon you wouldn't
boast that you are an amateur
neurosurgeon
there's no i don't know any other
profession
where if you put amateur in front of it
that someone said hey
that's so it's it i think it may be
unique
in that regard i'm just yeah i'm just
saying that's right yeah
there are some amateur rocket scientists
but normally they they win the darwin
award they don't win the nobel prize but
they win the door
[Laughter]
well i i want to start today with uh
with an amateur avocation that i learned
about from a
colleague who will remain nameless and i
want to reflect first of all on this
figure here who is the first
professional
astronomer to use a telescope can you
recognize this man of course
and we want to get a finger puppeteer
who do you think who are you
who
what i didn't do any show prep neil come
on give me
you're gonna hold up a finger puppet of
galileo in his
period garb all right with his bald ass
head
and his you know beard and you're gonna
and he's holding a telescope
ask me who the hell he is your big shot
who's this he's in his garb too
do you know who that oh wait a minute
i'm giving it away i'm giving it away
do you recognize this man he's been a
guest on my podcast
oh noam chomsky okay he's got a doll
and then of course we're going to talk
about this man uh who you will recognize
how many finger puppets do you have well
i was going to ask you if you'd like to
be a finger puppet but that's impolite
until the end of the interview neil i
don't want to go
too blue in the interview yet but do you
recognize this gentleman
carl sagan the turtleneck gives it away
the turtle you know when i hosted cosmos
i wanted at least one episode where i
got to wear a turtleneck
and i did wear a turtleneck but it
wasn't like full up the neck
it was like one of these half
turtlenecks and i said all right
if that's as much as as an homage carl
is going to get
since styles have changed four times
over since then
so we'll give him a half turtle length
so i thought i'd look pretty sharp in a
jacket and a half turtleneck in a few of
those scenes he did too
and i shared those feelings with none
other than andrew and your partner in
crime who was a guest on the podcast and
along with her daughter
sasha sagan who was a uh appeared in one
of the episodes
i think playing her grandmother yes in
this episode sasha was a guest on the
podcast too so i've had mother and
daughter it was crunchy
she played carl sagan's mother that's
right her grandmother right yes
um her own grandmother yes sorry yes and
then i have coming up so i've had a
mother-daughter pair
and then soon i'm going to have your
friend sylvester james gates who's one
of my best friends as well
i had him on three times so far and i'm
having his daughter delilah who's
graduating from your alma mater
currently into black holes
oh my gosh exactly so she's gonna be out
so it's gonna be father daughter and i'm
gonna try to make up all the pairs
and i'll let you know how that goes but
you have access to all these people you
don't need me
on your show yeah what am i doing on why
am i here
you get all the science you want
well you know i said i'm just saying
usually when i'm a podcast guest
the the podcaster has no access to any
scientist in the world because no
because they either don't know them when
they may contact this
the scientist looks at the rest of their
podcast and say no way my appearance on
that episode
so i become the token scientist and so i
don't know
what you're going to do with me for this
hour but i'm here i'm here for you
the hardest one to get you know i had on
jessica mayer dr jessica mayer while she
was on the freaking space station
she was easier to get than you so this
is about five years in the making
where i even wrote a book with norton so
that i could get close to uh
to you via one of your books and with uh
aaron lovett who is my
publicist as well as your publicist and
i wrote a book just so i could get close
to you
never materialized when that book came
out now we got some time thanks to a
global pandemic
and i want to thank you again for coming
on i'll read your bio later i don't want
to waste your time with your own bio
um unless you want me to present the
rebuttal to your no no i'm not going to
present the right
first i want to start with a rumor uh
that you
are uh an anaphile which sounds dirty
but it's not
it's like syzygy things in in science
that sound dirty but they're not
so i've been told that you are a wine
aficionado and i want to read a quote
by this man galileo galilei he said the
sun
with all those nine planets including
pluto no he didn't say that he said the
sun
with all those planets revolving around
it and dependent
upon it can still ripen a bunch of
grapes
as if it had nothing else in the
universe to do
what is it about wine or grapes or what
have you
what about wine fascinates you that you
become an amateur
wine aficionado and in a file
uh so galileo's not alone
in having spoken of wine and that's not
even his only wine quote
another wine quote i'll mangle it but it
goes something like
uh wine is
water made in sunlight or something
all right this is so again he's got that
cosmic reference but still very
terrestrial let's remind ourselves that
galileo
is still yes he's a brilliant scientist
but he's still italian
[Laughter]
don't let that fact escape you okay
the boy lived in italy all right and so
did some good eating and good drinking
in italy where is it wonderful
i don't know if it was fully called
italy back in 1609 but
um i guess it was they were city states
back then
right but the uh so also
the monk uh dom perrion when he sort of
stumbled on the double fermentation
of yeast where the first fermentation
you
first round you get alcohol
having converted the sugars but if it
double ferments
then it becomes carbon dioxide
and he sees it he says oh my gosh i've
made a mistake and then he tastes it
and then he says i believe i'm tasting
the stars
wow and thus was born the legacy of don
perrion
champagne so i think
when i think of wine other than
attending wine tastings where the wine
is the object of what's going on
i generally only have wine with meals
and if having wine with meal then it
becomes a culinary experience
not just a drinking experience right so
that and if you're having a meal and i'm
not a heavy drinker so
if i have a bottle of wine i need more
than me
to consume that bottle of wine so
generally
if i'm having the meal and i'm having
wine there are other people at the table
so the wine not only serves you
um serves your your appetite
your stomach it also serves a social
role
and uh so i value the juxtaposition of
these forces
on what it is to be human and
uh as you noted i i study wines
almost academically not that i publish
papers in it but i i like
knowing about it and i like knowing that
different parts of the world
grow different grapes depending on the
climate and the soils and the
sunlight and and and they develop food
that rises up and somehow works really
well with the wine grown
in the region the best barolo
italian wine that i've ever had
was in italy okay and i'm sitting on a
porch and there's a there's a
there's a there's a rock face in front
of me the
you know cliff and a and the weather and
the breeze and the language
and i don't know if that was actually
the best barolo i'd ever had
but somehow everything worked in that
moment
so so i try to be culturally respectful
of wines because you can if you collect
wine you have wine from all around the
world
sometimes you can get over focused and
you only drink one kind of wine i don't
that i don't think that's good yeah i
think you're missing out
and so uh any meal that we prepared my
wife and i prepare
if it even smacks in the slightest bit
of
being italian i'm opening an italian
wine well
and a french meal it's a french if i'm
getting like a steak
you know omaha steak i'm opening a
california wine
we got something uh i'll open me an
american wine
so so it it it stimulates
cultural awareness and sensitivity it's
it's it's a social force
and you know when you imagine a bar
fight okay it's typically of course
between
two men um does that bar fight happen
while the two of them are sipping a
glass of merlot
leads to bar brawl tonight
it's kind of you know so
i've never seen people break out into a
bar fight
over their glass of zinfandel all right
so
so um there's something peaceful about
it something
congenial about it that is not mirrored
in a
in a shot of whiskey just in practice
and
and even beer right um and so
anyhow so that's why i embrace the the
culture the
the efforts of the wine makers and by
the way
you didn't ask this but it's a good
place to volunteer it
there is data there are data
going back centuries
in vineyards of when
there was the harvest and when they had
rains and this is some of the best
data around on the agricultural
consequences of climate change
amazing yeah and i wanted to i don't
know if you know this but i'm a
practicing jew i'm not as orthodox as
our friend ben shapiro whose
show you went on just a few weeks after
i went on his show a couple years ago
and ben is of course full jew i'm only
you know kind of semi-jew
but nevertheless uh i mean you're a jew
that's right
uh but every friday night the jews do
what is called kidush or
or sanctification it's meant to separate
the
holy day of shabbat the sabbath uh from
the rest of the week where we must work
we're commanded to work
and you celebrate that event with wine
you must celebrate it with wine or
it could be grape juice if you're a
teetotaler but when you do that
you invoke the fact that god according
to the hebrew tradition
uh not only led us out of egypt but also
created the universe
in other words we are celebrating with
wine not in that order
that's right yeah yeah i want to be
clear just the way you said it
you said that as though letting you out
of egypt was the big task
oh and by the way he created the
universe you know just can we
prioritize this please
that's very good yeah so um so i want to
turn next to another uh great
great scientifically inclined individual
who is a hero of yours and also of one
of my heroes who lives downtown from you
or maybe uptown i don't know where you
are right now but jim simons
so jim simons is the patron of the
simon's observatory which i am
privileged to
co-lead with 300 of the brightest human
beings on the planet
we're seeking cosmic origins through the
cosmic microwave background radiation
i interviewed jim simons last year on
father's day
and i asked him who is the person in
history that you'd most like to have a
dinner with a glass of wine with so to
speak
and he said abraham lincoln without
batting an eye or without batting an
eyelash i don't know what you bat first
but
um lincoln means a lot to you and i
wonder if we could speak a little bit
about uh
the the aspects of leadership i don't
think you've talked so much about this
you are a leader
in the field first of all you are the
most famous i did a google search
and i said who's the most famous
scientist in history by amount of
searches so
you know einstein gets searched and
hawking gets searched but by sheer
number of people who know you neil
you're the most well-known scientist
probably in human history because of the
internet of course and because of all
the
amazing work that you do to broaden
awareness of science
i'm not expecting you to reply to that
uh without another bottle of barolo
but um but i want to talk about
leadership because i think that's that's
a role that people don't really
appreciate you are the leader
essentially of the hayden planetarium uh
you've been in this role in science
leadership for years
you've written books what is leadership
to you can you
be taught to be a good leader did you
study to be a good leader
how does that instantiate itself in your
life
thanks for that question so first of all
um if uh i would hesitate to declare
that uh metrics
offered by the internet mean anything at
all
i don't know i would i would re-evaluate
your your how you're going about that
that that search
um so my first comment second
um you mentioned lincoln i
i got associated with abraham lincoln
not from my own
natural causes i was approached
by the there's a foundation the lincoln
library foundation i think it's called
uh if i don't if that's not exactly what
it's called it
smells like that right and they wanted
me
to reflect
on the gettysburg address and they were
going to collect
uh people's reflections and put it in a
book but they wanted
people from all different walks of life
to do so so
politicians economists um
and so they they had to throw a
scientist in there so i guess i
i they pulled the short straw for me to
do this
and the task was uh the gettysburg
address is 242 words
something like that one of the shortest
most significant
addresses ever given by anyone and we
were to
write 242 words
on how and why the gettysburg address
and or
lincoln means what they mean to you
and you're supposed to take personally
so i said
you know i'm a scientist and i don't so
you know even though
my skin color is dark i'm not going to
be the one who's going oh [ __ ] free
this
i'm not going to be that person because
that's not what i carved in my life
all right i didn't lead a life chanting
how segregation is bad that's a
different kind of profession than
an astrophysicist so i said how can i
make this relevant
i thought i thought a long time about it
i said i got it
oh yeah yeah
okay you know what lincoln did in 1863
when clearly he had other issues in
front of him like
the civil war like gettysburg
like okay what else he did in 1863
he founded the national academy of
sciences
and i was so struck by that among other
things that he did he established the
land grant
university system he the things that
that he's not remembered for because
there's so many other
really important things for why you
would remember him
okay reasons for remembering so so i
composed 242 words
celebrating the national academy of
sciences that's what i did
and then that got uh it got
illustrated and it's on youtube and so
for me i wasn't so much commenting or
reflecting on his
urge to keep the country together and
the politics that that
necessitated and you know if you saw the
movie lincoln
you it shows you what's going on under
the hood um
i think doris kearns goodwin it was
based on her story or her she was
advisor to it
based on her books but you you see the
actual politics that is unfolding
under the hood uh that is not otherwise
apparent when you just
read a surface account of the history so
um so i wasn't so much reflecting on his
leadership
as on his foresight the foresight
to create such a thing as a national
academy of sciences
at a time when we're transitioning from
a backwards country
into one of the uh the the
one of the leaders of an industrial
revolution
we didn't start it but we certainly
ratcheted it up
but in the second half for the sec the
last quarter of the 19th century
going into the 20th century and beyond
so that's that connection now you want
to ask about leadership
i i never think about it
here's what i think about as an educator
especially
i say to myself am i offering something
that people
want and that they value
so if i do
then they follow all right
and i guess you can measure sort of
internet
value that way by how many followers you
have
and i have like a crazy number of
twitter followers
and i i wake up every morning say you
know do you realize you're following an
astrophysicist
you can still back out there's still
time you know
you this is not i didn't this is not a
requirement
all right and so for me
leadership is not
telling people to follow you that's not
it
leadership is not well let me do
something great
and then everyone follows me because i
did something
great i would say most leaders in
history
satisfy that criterion you know how else
does
grant become president except that he
commanded the union armies
all right how does how else does
eisenhower
become president except that he was a
five-star general and
so these are people who did great things
and if in that context you think of war
and winning a war as a great thing
he did great things and then he's on
george washington you know how many
presidents
did something great and then everyone
follows them
uh so that's not how i think about
leadership
i think a leader is someone
who has followers
because the followers derive
something from it
and you know it was steve jobs a leader
sure but is he a leader because i said i
want to be steve no because he created
products that people
liked all right so people just
came to accreted to him because he kept
serving them
okay so all i can say is
if i have as many followers as i do it's
because i'm
feeding people okay i'm feeding them
and the moment someone comes up to me in
the street and says
oh are you you need to ask i said yes oh
um can i have your autograph what's your
favorite color can we take a selfie if
those are the only three questions you
ask me
then i have failed as an educator
because then you're
what you're there you're building
personality and that's cult that's cult
building
if if you are the object of their
destination
rather than the messages you have and
the themes and the ideas
that they then attach to so that's how i
think about leadership so another
connection with
jim simons the the leader of the simon's
foundation the creator of the churn
simon's
metric invariant topological form uh
is uh is it comes together with his
notion of the the value or or somehow
the perils of being famous
and he's famous for saying because he's
rumored to be the world's smartest
billionaire
and i've done charitable events with him
where you know people come up to him and
won't leave him alone and he said to me
once he said brian
you know um i'm one of the richest
people in the world but if i gave a
dollar to everyone who told me they're a
genius
even i'd be broke uh but one thing he
said once to me
he said um or he's rumored to say is
from the movie as from the book
uh animal farm where uh there's a donkey
character named benjamin
and there's a pig so so this is the
george orwell
novel not the movie
so uh no sorry an animal house sorry
animal
george orwell yeah yeah sorry i don't
want to confuse the two
yes these are not the same things animal
house animal farm go on
the pig says i'm jealous of you benjamin
the donkey because you have this long
luxurious tail
and uh and i have this short little
curly thing that doesn't do anything
and benjamin the donkey says uh yeah
that's true i had the lord gave me a
long tail
to swat away the flies but i'd rather
not have the flies and not need the tail
and you know i wonder sometimes because
you are besieging and i did talk with
our mutual friend david spurgle
uh who has you know the utmost
admiration for you but he's like i don't
know how neil does i mean you can't walk
down the street
my friend cindy lawrence who's the ceo
of the museum of mathematics downtown
new york he's just so gracious you're so
always so gracious
how do you handle that would you trade
the tail you know to not have the fly so
to speak and i'm not calling your
followers flies please
[Laughter]
yes you did let the record show
let the record show okay just knit
no no let me take it another step uh let
the record show that he really wants me
to be a pig
proclivities
plus i think flies also hang around pigs
so
yeah i'm pretty sure they also hang
around pigs but the
but what do i know i'm a city kid
so my visibility
fame if you want to call it that
happened
adiabatically if i want to sort of stoke
the physics vocabulary
of your of your legacy on the show
and so there wasn't nothing happened
overnight
there can be actors who who slave away
and regional theater and then they get
spotted by a casting agent and then they
star in a movie and then everyone knows
their name the day after
uh that would require abrupt adjustments
that people
don't always um survive
all right especially if if you're a
child actor you know how does that work
or
even athletes who come out of college
and then they have a 10 million
contract and they're famous and rich
overnight all right
now 50 million dollar contract so it
happened
slowly which allowed me to make
adjustments
slowly without it being
catastrophic in my life and they're very
explicit metrics of this so pre-internet
all right it's it's how many total
strangers recognize me in the street
it'll be like one a month and then it
was like one a week
then it was five a week
then it was five a day
then it was ten a day
and it was a hundred a day there was a
thousand a day
okay and then it's a point where the
measurement is not meaningful
uh and so so i have tactics and
methods and and and the things i do
that that can open the doors and then
close the doors effectively and
efficiently when i have the time
energy and interest to serve this
audience that i have cultivated
over all this time so so
um the thing is
simon's could have been rich
with no one recognizing him at all
except that he's done very visible
things by creating a very visible
foundation and
agencies and organizations and
he's got a very visible yacht called the
archimedes right so
he does very visible things so now he's
recognized and everyone wants a piece of
him
he could have just stayed in the back
there plenty of billionaires you cannot
recite their name
and you would walk past them in the
street and never know
so i don't i'm not accepting
his declaration that oh i wish i was
this but
with but without the that because he
could have controlled it whereas my
very visibility is the product of very
deliberate actions i have taken in
serving the public
so and by the way the people who are
famous who never wanted to be famous
all right people who like stumbled on
fame it's kind of unfair
at that point that they get crowded and
chased down because they didn't bargain
for it they didn't want it they didn't
you know if you're a kid of someone
famous and you're about to inherit it
you know
the the the the descendants of the getty
fortune or the
fortune you know you're you're rich and
the tabloids want to write about you and
you really just want to
live life no it's different if you're
paris hilton
right because then part of her
her identity is being this sort of uh
wealthy heiress right so
so um speaking sort of
capitalistically about this um
no no speaking let me say that
differently i
uh it's hard for fame in the united
states to not be associated with wealth
because opportunities arise and people
pay you to make this happen
okay um i would love nothing more
to write some best-selling books and
they just go to the bahamas
on your mega yacht find me in the
bahamas
that would be a nice sort of round that
out the pluto
oh my gosh well no i have to call the
hades you know get get really deep in
there
on it um no no no so the uh
what's the name of the boat that crossed
the river sticks
that would be the better name for it i
think that boat had
okay so let me just say that i have um
learned to deal with
the fame and it's thousands a day so
i wear a hat i can wear glasses and
but there's another sort of access point
to me that i can't
control and that's there are people who
are like five feet away
behind me and then they hear my voice
this i recognize that voice and then
they come up and you're near and
meanwhile i got the dark glasses on and
then
stealth mode visual stuff but auditory
stealth i don't i don't know how to
change my voice
so what it has done is it means i can't
really tour
museums i can't go shopping
easily so i do a lot of ordering or my
wife does a lot of
shopping or i'll go very early in the
morning when hardly anyone else is there
and wear the hat and the and the glasses
um during covet i've had there's a whole
mask in front of my whole face
right so that's been pretty good but
then some people like look a little
extra long at my eyes
and then sometimes they'll do a thumbs
up or something thing
so i say damn but if you can see me
through my covet mask and my hat
i got to give it to you i got to give it
to you if you if you if you get that
deep
into who i am you know nothing i can say
so no i'm okay with the tail um i'm okay
with this
question just came to me but it's
courtesy of our mutual friend stefan
alexander can you repeat what you said
he should change his name to because i
wasn't recording in the beginning for
stefan alexander
president of the national black society
of black physicist and full professor at
brown university
what should stefan change hi solomon too
oh jazz
yeah yeah jazz you were a
very talented wrestler uh in as a
younger person
i would say that differently uh though i
was captain of my high school team and
undefeated
um let me remind you that was a
wrestling team
in new york city it was not a wrestling
team in in
iowa or oklahoma or
you go there then boys are corn fed
and they're hauling steer on their back
as
teenagers and then they put them on the
mat okay so when i got to college i had
a losing record until my senior year
even and but i enjoyed the sport so
deeply that that didn't matter i was
better at other sports actually
um and i was better at rowing for
example but
the the sheer purity of what it was to
wrestle is what attracted me
does that give you a confidence i mean
you're a physically imposing
personality um does that aid you the
fact that you have trained in
is it martial art um do you do you find
that it does broaden
you know uh i know you talked about this
on uh you know star talk and in the
sports
uh segment thereof but um does it aid
you i mean does it give you the
confidence that
say a normal pencil like astrophysicists
such as yours truly might not have no i
i try to do some martial arts but
does it make you more confident
especially in public when you're dealing
with people you don't know who the hell
this person is coming up
i'm running he's coming up with a pen or
i don't know what the hell he's doing i
mean how do you
does it give you confidence or you know
can you never let down your guard
well so you're using confidence
in one way where i think most people
when they heard your question
might have thought of it the other way
so there is what kind of confidence you
just have in yourself
and your own presence when you're giving
a public talk
or when you're among colleagues there
are things that can boost
just your sense of yourself that's one
kind of confidence but
the way you're asking about the
confidence is does it give me the
confidence to kick someone's ass if i
have to
that's really what you are asking there
so i
since my eyes are in my own head and i
just look out and see the rest of the
world i don't look
at myself so i don't think of myself as
imposing
i'm not crazy tall i'm six feet two
and i've probably shrunk a half inch in
the last 30 years
um six two that you wouldn't say that's
a tall go go talk to that tall person
over there no that's not how that comes
out
um i have a body mass all right
um i got a nice middle-aged man belly
but i think i
i think i wear it i don't say well
um i i i don't think i'm sloppy about it
that's what i might say right
and so but would you say go to that big
guy over in the corner
i don't think i'm that person who gets
that description
so as a result when you say i'm imposing
i don't think of myself as imposing for
that reason
i think of people 250 300 pounds six
foot five
they're imposing in any room they walk
into so
now that being said um i
actively train my reflexes
and
[Music]
actively and i do strength training
stretching
not as strong as i used to be but
when someone comes near me at all times
i'm
doing a calculation if they lunge
towards me
with a weapon or knife or a letter
opener
as someone had once stabbed martin
luther king
um i
judge whether i can back up block
grab respond in the time the person
would even think to do so i
that's an active thought i have and it's
not just from wrestling i did read a lot
about
the the asian martial arts uh
you know taekwondo karate kung fu
especially was a big fan of bruce lee
and who wasn't of course so i
tested to see if my body could move the
way martial arts experts could move
and for a while i could do a full split
i can kick above my head
i could do things and that gave me
certain physical confidence walking down
the street now here's the rub here
is that at my size
i'm probably the last person who needed
to be able to defend myself in the
street
against some thug because thugs don't
pick on people
that are bigger than they are it doesn't
work that way
uh so and and here's something that you
might appreciate
when i was in high school cause i was a
geek from way back um
i wanted the superhero i wanted to be
was
the i wanted to be the protector of
geeks
and there'd be some bat symbol that
would go up like digits of pi
or something would reflect on the clouds
and then i would come running because i
was physically enabled from very early
on
and bigger than most other kids in my
class
and and i started wrestling in
high school and so it was i thought to
myself
if i'm athletic but i'm also geeky then
i appreciate
the geek space the geek unit of the
geeker verse
but i also have the strength and agility
of all these athletes who would
otherwise be giving wedgies to the geeks
so i imagine myself as their protector
this is my one little
fantasy that i had you provoke the geeks
when they when they double check your
calculations on how much a football
deflects on super bowl sunday away or
towards the goal post based on the
choreo
i know let him do it stop
but i have to ask you because you
brought up leadership in the context of
teaching
and uh my russian friends i was mentored
by the the mentee
is that a word mento i don't know anyway
the protege
mentee mentee famous astrophysicist from
the former soviet union
and his student alexander palmer taught
me that the word scientist
in the russian language means someone
who was taught
probably a dude who was taught a man who
was taught but it means a person who was
taught and to me
that means that we as scientists sort of
have an obligation
to teach uh because the supposition is
we're going to pay it forward we're not
just going to
oh here's all this knowledge thank you
so much so i want to talk about the
influence of belief in you
from an early age obviously carl sagan
is a huge influence in in your life
um and those those sort of lessons do
you think that because you were kind of
um maybe singled out in a good way from
a young age that too
gave you confidence and i'm not again
i'm not using confidence as a substitute
for arrogance or anything like that i'm
just saying
you have a pretty natural gift and might
be god-given if you
i know you don't fully believe in god
but but anyway it might be nature given
evolution given
whatever you want to say thor zeus who
what have you but the point is
you you have certain gifts and and it's
one of those the fact that it was kind
of
um the metagenomics or what are they
called epigenomics of
having confidence being you know
talented naturally
but also having people have confidence
in you that's not that made you
you know kind of succeed in the way that
you flourished
no
no it was it was completely
tap rooted within me and
and i i think that's not common i think
many people
benefit from encouragement but my
interests were
sort of homegrown i was not fulfilling
some
success or failures of my parents uh as
is occasionally the pressure that's put
on the next generation
i want you to be the doctor that i
couldn't be or i'm a doctor so you're
gonna be
that none of that was there so the carl
sagan encounter was when i was in
high school i was 15. and no no no no i
was uh
i was at 75 17 i was 17
transitioning to go into college and but
i'd known since i was nine
that i wanted to study the universe so
this and everything so
i i was not dependent on whether other
people were going to have confidence in
me
especially considering that most people
didn't most people i'm referring to
teachers
there is no teacher at any time in my
academic trajectory
who at the time would have said hey see
that guy tyson over there his he'll go
far
watch him he he's the one you meanwhile
i know
what my ambitions are but it doesn't
manifest in their classroom
and teachers are kind of limited in
their assessment of you by how you
perform
in their classroom that was highly
social uh disruptive in class not
in an angry way or it's just there was
an energy that bubbled out of me
so i i was never considered a great
student by teachers that's first point
second point um
i'm gonna call you out on something you
ready are you seated
i'm ready i got i got my hold on let me
get my scotch
ford of fun okay go for it
i'm gonna pull the race card on you are
you ready
this has never happened before on the
into the impossible podcast go for it
uh there is a tendency
for a white person
upon seeing a highly talented black
person
to say oh it's a gift it's just genetic
it's just rather than say boy you must
have worked
really hard to achieve that
and that disconnect
manifested in your very question to me
because you it was not even in you to
imagine
that i wasn't good at communicating at
some early point where i said well how
can i get better at this let me think
about this
and uh here's an example of how it got
manifested okay
when i got my first invitation to appear
on the daily show
with jon stewart i said oh my gosh
that's dangerous this guy's all in your
face
let me watch a few of these shows so i
watched it
and i timed how many seconds he gives
his guests
to speak before he interrupts
comedically
and if you're a politician you've got
your stump speech and you've got to get
it out and he interrupts it oh my gosh
you're flustered
and you're dear in the freaking
headlights so i said that is not going
to happen to me
so i timed this so i said i'm going to
parcel my
information that i'm going to share in
that in that
show in six to nine second increments
so that when he does jump in the thought
has been completed then we can both
laugh
and then i go on to the next thought and
there's no deer in the headlights
not only that not only that
not only that i monitored how far back
he reaches for a current event that he
will then throw into the mix
and he doesn't go back more than about
three days there's a news cycling
because if he makes a current event
reference and it's not current
then it doesn't hit as a joke you have
to say oh well that happened last week
is that relevant now so i would study
current events for the previous three
days deeply i'd bring that to bear on
those conversations
and i'm invited back 14 times and what
do people say
neil you're such a natural on his show
o'neil the chemistry between you is so
natural well you have a gift
this is what i live through another one
i give a public talk sorry sorry i have
to i have to interrupt because i have to
tell you something
because part of what my essence is is
expressing gratitude
not only did i know that story about you
i learned it from david spurgle two
years ago
before i myself went on ben shapiro show
when i felt the terror
of that you must have felt the first ah
who am i i'm some astrophysicist from
from california
i was going on this show that could be
seen by millions of people by the way
he's very controversial as you know
and i said david what does neil do and
david explain to me
exactly the vignette that you just told
me so i know better than anybody and not
only did i know that neil
i followed the tyson approach to being
in a high-stress interview situation so
i just want you to know
i would never underestimate the amount
of hard work you put in and i want to
thank you because you enabled me to
perform
marginally okay not as well as you did
on ben show but nevertheless i used the
tyson technique and that is
that was very key to my to my success
well thank you and i'm gonna add to that
uh thanks for adding that prefer
for for throwing that in the mix there
so on another occasion i give a public
talk
right and uh and then the people enjoy
it and they clap at the end
and then so i get two responses
typically
all right i'm bending them into two bins
but there are other
there's nuances there as well one kind
of response is
you are having such a good time up there
on stage
okay and another response is you are
working hard
up there and to a person
those who say i was working hard or
school teachers
because they saw what i was doing and
how i was doing it
and why i was doing it and they
appreciated the invested
effort for what that was so i'm just
saying
no i don't think any of it is a gift and
no teacher in the history of my life
would have said so um and not only that
i got another one for you you ready uh
so i've written yeah
[Laughter]
my verbal sats were okay but again they
weren't the kind of score where you'd
hey watch that person they'll go far
wasn't any of that
well 15 years
after i'd taken the sats and got my phd
and i have a column that i write
for natural history magazine uh one of
the more honor
honorific things i've done because
that's a magazine that stephen j
gould wrote for and i was we were
bookending the middle section of that
with he wrote on nature and i wrote on
the universe but anyhow
i got a letter in the mail from the
educational testing service these the
purveyors of the
of the s.a.t and just to show you what
of a grip they have on us it was like
what happened to my scores it's still
affecting you
like emotional i said well they must
know something because it was addressed
to
dr neil degrasse tyson so i said okay
some somebody updated their file
and i open it up and it says dear dr
tyson we've read a recent essay of yours
and uh we and we we liked how it worked
and what it did we want to excerpt these
three paragraphs
for our verbal s.a.t that we were
writing
for the reading comprehension it was
like i wanted to say
[ __ ] you okay that's my first thought
then i said no that wouldn't be
productive and i said okay
uh yes i grant you permission for this
so this is a this is an organization
where i take an exam where my score is
not high enough
for anyone to say he'll go far
and now they're coming to me for my
writing sample to put on a test that
they're going to administer to other
people
that's messed up okay okay that's just
messed up and in there later on okay a
lot of that content would be called and
i
would write astrophysics for people in a
hurry which was
like a press yes thank you for
picking up a copy um and that was on the
new york times bestseller list for 82
weeks
it was on so long that my next book came
out and they both showed up briefly
together
on the list so so when i hear people
saying oh you have a gift
you must have known this this is not i
don't go through life
relying on what other people say about
my potential right
i had to generate it from within
otherwise i would be deluded
either thinking i'm greater than i am
because family members love you
or less than i am because they're people
who have no clue what they're talking
about
and that's my long reply to your very
simple and direct i appreciate that
about
what i'm doing is my life you know now
eviscerates my next question which also
came
courtesy of a fellow african-american
physicist from the bronx who went to
your rival school dewitt clinton
and that's stefan alexander and he said
and often in his life he was pushed
towards athletics and not towards uh not
towards science
and he said that of you too that your
teachers were pushing you towards out so
i did do this research you know to make
sure that
you know that this this is a common
theme and it's just a question of when i
talk to people like jim gates
or you know when i talk to uh moya
mcteer or whatever
uh there are two types i'm gonna not
play the race card because i can't play
the race card
i'll play the jewish card sometimes but
but i i don't usually do that
um but what is how is that pressure
because you're layered on top of that as
well like
not only do you have to do this uh jim
gates or stefan alexander
but you also have to speak for you know
i mean that to me
i've said it to them i've said it to my
friend gentry patrick who's uh actually
engaged to my cousin now
and here at ucsd so he's now the only
relative that's been on the show
i said you guys pay a tax you
african-american colleagues of mine
you pay an extra tax i don't have to pay
it but um
but i but i wonder you know in our age
right now
um are things getting better are things
improving
um when i'm told that my department is
systemically racist for example
i i push back i hate racist neil i punch
him in the freaking face
um but i know that the system has a lot
of lacunae in it
and so what do i do as someone who wants
to do well and doesn't want to say that
you know i'm an anti-racist and i have
to do anti-racism in order to prove them
anti-racist
it seems like michael sherman our mutual
friend says that's a tautology basically
do you have any advice for an academia
or scientific research for how to
make it better or maybe by reducing the
burden that african-american
colleagues have to have to pay
just at all times ask yourself would you
say this to someone who had lighter
color skin
would you say this to someone who is
female would you say this to someone
who is just ask if you would say exactly
that same thing
okay well when i give a talk and i have
a white person come up to me and say oh
that was articulate
would you say that to a white person no
you wouldn't
all right so why are you saying it to a
black person and
i think that's the litmus test just sort
of you know when i'm waiting in line
to get on the plane and i have a first
class ticket and the flight attendant
this is before i was recognizable
the flight attendant would say oh oh
this is the first class line
like i didn't know i couldn't figure it
out on my own and i belonged on another
line
would you say that to a white person
standing in front of you
such as that and this is even if i'm in
a suit and tie so
so that's really i think it works
it works really well and i do i do that
all the time
it's how i see it in others and i have
it i might even see it
myself um and so i i try to
and it's a constant editing but
i don't want to say it as though it's
something that is a chore
it's something that is a it is a duty
it is this way progressive thinking
i think is what all of us should be
invoking
at all times i want to ask and not
enough of us that you've worked a lot on
as far as i can tell because no one is
born with disability and that's as a
communicator as a podcaster specifically
so i get a lot of people tomorrow my uh
colleague michio kaku is coming on the
end of the impossible podcast
and he's here to talk about his new book
the god equation
and if you if you have a few more
minutes i do want to get into
some of the hype and and so forth but i
really want to talk about the physics
behind some of this
if you'll indulge me in just a bit but
first of all i want to get your advice
as a master podcast when you're talking
to somebody and they're talking bs
what do you do what do you do when
someone's talking about the mind of god
and the god equation and
and this and then that and and you know
it's for book sales i mean at some level
how do you handle that because you want
to be you don't want to be rude to your
guests right you want to have guests to
say good things about you
i i don't think it's it's not about
whether you're rude
it's about whether you're truthful it's
about whether you're honest it's about
whether you
are you are it's possible to be truthful
and rude
and truthful and just pleasant right
there
and this these are social or dare i call
them tactics methods tools
uh this is why some people attract
friends and others
uh you know repel friends right so
so um so
i don't i recognize the human
condition and what is the human
condition it's just people
think differently from each other and
one another
people have different values
they they have different life
experiences and
that's what creates the beautiful
diversity of the world
and i have come to embrace that so
i'll give an example we're about to film
for cosmos on the ledge of the grand
canyon but the spot where we wanted to
do it
happen to be uh native land and so we
get permission to film then they grant
permission
and one of the nate the the regional
elders
knew that i saw that i was coming wanted
to meet me they came up we shook hands
and he said i'd like to
say a a prayer a native prayer
as we look over the edge of the grand
canyon
and so we we um held hands he showed me
how to do that
and then out comes this prayer i'm not
going to say why are you doing this this
is stupid this is no i'm not going to do
that
this is we are all human beings we all
have our cultural
rituals i don't bust into your seder
and say really you have an empty seat
there for elijah
really you know and you unlock the door
really you really think that's going to
happen no you're going to say no this is
ritual
and that's what binds us okay as a
community whether or not you believe
it is literal and so i will never
disrupt a ritual provided the ritual
doesn't harm other people
right this is the whole point about what
it is to be free you're free as long as
you don't take away someone else's
freedom if someone wants to
call the higgs boson the guard the god
particle
if someone wants to believe that the god
created the universe
i i'm not gonna hit him on the head
if this is consistent with their outlook
on the world
i'll teach him what we know about a big
bang and let them decide
what they want to do i just don't do
that
i don't see the point now if you want to
say
you know the universe was created in six
days i said we have strong
evidence that it wasn't uh are you
interested if they say no
the one we're going to chase after them
what what do you want me to do the whole
point of living in the united states of
[ __ ] america
is that people have free expression of
religion that's kind of what it's all
about
it's in the it's in the the the first
amendment
okay the second whichever a high
amendment
free expression of religion all right so
so so that's kind of an interesting fact
so you can't have free expression of
religion and then complain that people
are expressing their religion
you can't do that now what i can do is
say stay out of my science classroom
because it's not science i didn't knock
down the door of your sunday school did
i
or in your synagogue i didn't jump into
your hebrew school and say that might
not necessarily have been true
i didn't i didn't go in there do that so
why do you feel you have the right to
change my science curriculum
that's where it gets sort of politically
strategic and ugly sometimes and you
have court cases and things
but overall you have a buddhist over
here a muslim over there
you know go for somebody like sir roger
penrose who you've interviewed you've
been with
you know and he might have a theory
that's not in the orthodoxy
of standard cosmology and he's pushing
it very hard now he's got a nobel prize
uh
he left it in my office when he was
visiting me so i i i got it for you sir
roger don't worry
i'm keeping it nice and safe but in
reality you know sometimes i'm thinking
like
you know do you believe that this
particular you know
model of the universe is true or not
obviously i'm going to be respectful but
i do push back and i guess my question
to you is
you know when do you lay off when when
you're satisfied you know carl had this
famous baloney detection kit
um do you have anything like that
operative a subroutine
that's cycling in the background that
like all right i got to move off of this
guy he's kind of being a quack
it was a baloney sandwich detection kit
okay
the b you need to be the full bs has to
be in there
just to be just to be clear so
uh when you have people who have it's
not whether they go against canon
that's not the point that all great
ideas go against canon that's not
we love it when that happens i i would
love nothing more
to have everything we know about physics
be completely rethought in some way that
gives us a deeper understanding of the
world
we would all embrace that and we all
want to be that person
but just because no one agrees with your
new hypothesis
doesn't mean your new hypothesis is
correct
okay so so if roger penrose has a new
idea of the universe and he's he's
he's a storied guy i mean the guy is uh
okay accomplishing this story that
doesn't mean his next idea is going to
be correct so now he comes up with an
unorthodox idea
if he can't convince anyone of it
i don't know what else to tell you if
he's heavily invested intellectually and
emotionally he'll go to his grave
thinking it
as fred hoyle did thinking that the
universe was a steady state
fred hoyle was in the office that i'm in
jeffrey burbidge's office at uc san
diego and you
must know of the burbidge burbidge hoyle
and fowler uh nuclear
yep and uh so this is jeffrey's old
office and he'd be rolling in his grave
if he knew a cosmologist a practicing
cosmologist was in it
oh wait wait somebody i don't know if i
fully answered your question so if a
colleague has a cockamamie idea
i say have you convinced anyone because
i'm not convinced if they haven't
then if no one you can't convince
anybody
don't start crying well the god no one
believed galileo the moment you
analogize yourself to galileo you've
crossed over
you've you've you what you're trying to
say is i am right
because all of you don't agree with me
and that's not reason
that's not evident that doesn't count as
evidence yeah i'd love to talk to you
more about that in the context of like
and stuff like that but i know you gotta
run it's been such a pleasure to me i'm
a bronx boy from
my second generation bronx boy i want to
send you love from the west coast and uh
i hope we meet in person someday
excellent we're in the bronx were you
did you hang out my mom and
and father from the mashalu parkway and
my wife's parents are also from gun hill
road that kind of area
okay cool cool brock's in the house okay
thanks for having me
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]